diese flucht der einbrecher endet anders
als alle denken nach einer filmreifen
verfolgungsjagd landen die einbrecher
nämlich im wasser gegen 3 uhr 30 in der
nacht bemerkte eine polizeistreife im
brandenburgischen großen bei berlin die
einbrecher in einer schule die männer
springen in zwei autos und rasen davon
die beamten verfolgen eines der autos
als die flüchtenden einbrecher auf die
landstraße abbiegen wollen verliert der
fahrer die kontrolle über das auto die
beiden ganoven landen direkt im oder
spree kanal die beiden berliner im alter
von 28 und 36 jahren können sich selbst
aus dem sinkenden auto befreien
schwimmen durch das eiskalte wasser an
land dort wartet aber bereits die
polizei auf sie und nimmt die täter fest
klitschnass und unterkühlt geht es für
die einbrecher in eine klinik zur
routineuntersuchung
anschließend wartet die justiz auf sie
der fluchtwagen wird nun aus dem wasser
geborgen der dritte täter im anderen
auto ist noch auf der flucht